part comic book Park ghost story part
nightmare fuel Guillermo del Toro's
Cabinet of Curiosities is a chilling
collection of terrifying tales and these
are the scariest moments warnings
spoilers ahead
in Lot 36 we meet Nick played by Tim
Blake Nelson a man who makes his living
by an abandoned storage lockers and
selling their contents after purchasing
a unit whose owner recently died he
takes some things to a collector named
Agatha among the unique items is an
unusual table it's Seance table
like
Ouija board seance
a bit more serious than that
this is no ordinary Seance table this
one has hidden drawers containing hidden
books Agatha brings in a man named
Roland who specializes in rare texts
he's ready to pay three hundred thousand
dollars for the sets but only if Nick
can produce the fourth missing volume
one that's meant to bind a demon to
Earth as they go back to find the text
Roland reveals the story of the original
owner of Lot 36 the German man who made
the horrific choice to offer his sister
Dottie as a vessel for a demon the men
discover a hidden room within the locker
that holds Dotty's decaying corpse
containing a demon in her hollowed-out
face Nick spots the fourth book just Out
Of Reach and though Roland warns him not
to touch it he cannot resist thus
breaking the spell thought he rises as
the Demon's tentacles reach out of her
face and Roland is devoured
set in Salem at the beginning of the
20th century the graveyard rat story
follows Mason a Gravedigger who turned
grave robber to pay off some of his
debts after coming up short he's
convinced that an unlikely suspect rats
are stealing the bodies along with the
valuables and then one night he has a
creepy Vision seeing a rat tail hanging
from his water-stained ceiling he gives
it a yank and the ceiling opens raining
rats all over him later on Earth in a
grave Mason finds an empty coffin and
then sees the body being dragged Away by
rats determined to retrieve his fortune
he follows it underground where are you
I will have my vengeance
soon enough the song comes face to face
with an enormous rat Queen looming with
drool dripping from her razor sharp tee
determined to retrieve the valuables he
goes on crawling through tunnels
battling the rat Queen and her babies
and even a reanimated skeleton making
his way toward what he hopes is a way
out Mason instead gets trapped in a
coffin trapped Forever by his own greed
and classic Horror Story fashion
Academy award-winning actor F Murray
Abraham plays Carl a medical examiner
dying of cancer his friend Sheriff
Craven played by Glenn Turman asks for
his help explaining some mysterious
deaths that occurred in the local mine
as Carl performs autopsies on the dead
Miners and Alien Parasite that's taken
over one of the miners bodies makes
itself known
are you I'm a traveler
tying Carl to an autopsy table the alien
creature prepares to transfer itself
from the miner's dead body into Carl's
living one while cutting itself open the
alien explains to Carl his plan to
murder the sheriff Carl figures out that
the creature has no senses of its own
which is why it needs a human body as
host acting fast Carl grabs an eye from
the alien's Dead Hand still tied to the
table the alien and its small
octopus-like True Form begins burrowing
into Carl he tries killing the creature
but can't reach it in a truly heroic
move Carl decides to sacrifice himself
by destroying his own body before the
alien can use it slicing his ears and
eyes with a scalpel saving his friend
and the world
the outside tells the Darkly comedic
tale of Stacy a socially awkward bank
teller desperate to fit in with her
co-workers coveting their beauty clothes
and perfect lives when she's invited to
one of their parties and given a box of
expensive lotion she's thrilled and
proceeds to slather it all over her face
but a horrible allergic reaction occurs
refusing to be deterred by her red itchy
peeling skin Stacy continues her regimen
even as her rash worsens and her devoted
husband Keith begs her to stop
no I I'm not talking to the TV
devoted to his wife and supportive of
her Taxidermy hobby Keith is a beacon of
sensibility Keith tries his best to be
supportive of Stacy and her
transformation Journey even as her skin
and mental state get worse finally it
proves to be too much even for him and
he insists that she stopped it's a
suggestion she doesn't appreciate to say
the least after killing her husband and
stuffing poor Keith like one of her
Taxidermy projects her sought after
makeover is finally complete
inspired by an HP Lovecraft story
pikmin's Model tells the tale of Richard
Pikmin played by Crispin Glover who
invites a young artist named William
Thurber played by Ben Barnes to look at
his extremely creepy paintings one of
the paintings depicts a woman a distant
relative in which who killed her husband
and served him to members of her coven
Pikmin taunts Thurber with the painting
and Thurber feels deeply Disturbed
looking at it years later Thurber
continues to be haunted by pikmin's work
plagued by Vivid nightmares including
one in which he walks into the dinner
party from the painting but his own head
is being served as the main course
jumping forward in time we now see
Thurber as an older man and with a wife
and son running his own museum but still
haunted by memories of Pikmin one day
Pikmin unexpectedly returns shocking
Thurber he asked Thurber to come to his
house to see some new paintings in an
attempt to save others from the madness
he suffered Thurber goes alone
oh I know you want to see more new
paintings
[Applause]
but seeing pikmin's new paintings
overwhelms Thurber unable to control his
rage and anguish after all the years of
Torment he shoots Pikmin and burns down
his house the next day when Thurber
takes his family to his Museum he's
shocked to see pikmin's paintings
hanging there and horrifyingly one of
thurber's colleagues Joe standing in
front of the work his eyes gouged out
his wife and child are also looking in a
painting and he makes them stop but it's
too late when Thurber returns home his
wife has gouged her eyes out most
horrifyingly she's also in the middle of
preparing their son's head for dinner
another HP Lovecraft inspired story this
dark fairy tale is brought to life by
Catherine Hardwick director of the
original Twilight it tells the story of
Walter played by Rupert Grint of Harry
Potter Fame a man obsessed with bringing
his twin sister who died when they were
young back to life he becomes part of
the spiritualist society and discovers a
potion that allows him to find his
sister in a place called The Realm of
the Dead Walter even manages to bring
her back to the land of the living
temporarily you brought it back with you
you'll have to Ripple
I just wanted my sister back Walter's
actions anger a witch named kazaya a
Sinister being who also resides in the
Underworld and wants Walter's sister to
stay there with skin like petrified wood
and branch-like hair she resembles a
gnarled Tree in human form her screams
sound like nails on a chalkboard and her
hair is burning embers Furious This
Witch tries to stab poor Walter in the
eye but his ghost sister saves him she
seems different now calmer telling
Walter she's not scared anymore by the
end of the episode poor Walter can't
really say the same for himself
Peter Weller the actor perhaps most
famously known as RoboCop stars in the
viewing as Lionel a wealthy and
eccentric elderly man who invites four
interesting people to his Mansion
there's a psychic named [ __ ] an
astrophysicist named Charlotte a
musician named Randall and a famous
novelist named guy set in the 1970s
debuting benefits from a very
distinctive 70s aesthetic matching this
story Slow Burn intensity as the plot
unfolds it becomes clear why Lionel has
gathered these people together as it
turns out Lionel needs their help
understanding an artifact he's kept
tucked away for years a strangely
unsettling object that he suspects could
be an alien life form
you see that eventually the group
awakens the artifact and as The
meteor-like Rock glows and cracks open a
gooey creature with worm-like tendrils
emerges those tendrils turn into demonic
horns releasing a terrible energy and a
high-pitched sound horribly targ's face
melts off and guy's head explodes which
allows the other two namely Charlotte
and Randall to get the heck out of there
before they meet their ends as well but
with the alien Unleashed into the World
by the end of the night it's not exactly
what you could call a happy ending
in a tale of quiet grief and haunted
houses married couple and ornithologist
Nancy and Edgar are grieving the loss of
their daughter but instead of dealing
with their Devastation in a healthy
manner they throw themselves further
into their work which is studying Birds
starring Andrew link and his Edgar and
Essie Davis as Nancy the episode follows
a couple as they move into an old house
on an isolated island eventually Nancy
starts feeling and seeing a mysterious
presence in the house discovering
through photos and letters that the
previous occupants a woman named
Claudette had suffered many tragedies in
the home
oh
my God who's that
Apparently after Claudette learned that
her husband was married to another woman
she also discovered she was pregnant the
husband abandoned her and their unborn
child who remained hidden away in the
creepy isolated home then the ghostly
sounds and sightings begin once Nancy
Hears A child crying and sees a little
boy standing at the top of the stairs
dripping wet after kneeling down to
comfort the child he turns to reveal a
decaying and water bloated face the
shock knocks Nancy to the floor and he
finally asked the groundskeeper about
Claudette and he tells her that she
accidentally killed her son drowning him
in the bathtub after which she killed
herself how did he die
he drowned
she drowned him didn't she
by the end of the murmuring it seems
that the biggest monster anyone could
face is grief
[Music]